Let X be a random variable,
and let g be a function.
We know that if g is linear,
then the expected value
of the function is the same
as that linear function
of the expected value.
On the other hand, we know
that when g is nonlinear,
in general, these two
quantities will not be related.
But there is a
special case in which
we can establish some relation
between these two quantities
in the form of an inequality.
This is Jensen's inequality,
which we're going to develop.
Jensen's inequality
applies to the special case
where g is a convex function.
I'm going to define
more precisely what it
means to be convex shortly.
But in terms of a
picture, it's a function
that has a shape of this kind.
So it tends to curve upwards.
So let us look at
a simple example.
Suppose that X is a
random variable that
can take two values
with equal probability.
So these two values have
both probability 1/2.
And this is our
function, g of x.
Since they take the two
values with equal probability,
the expected value is
going to be in the middle.
So this here is the
expected value of X.
And in particular,
this value here
is going to be g of the
expected value of X. Now,
the random variable g of
X will take this value
with probability
1/2, and it's going
to take that value
with probability 1/2.
What is the average of g of X,
the expected value of g of X?
It's going to be
1/2 of this value
plus 1/2 of this value, which
you can find as follows.
If you draw a straight line,
it's going to be this much.
So this quantity here is the
expected value of g of X.
And we see that in this example,
the expected value of g of X
is above the value
of g evaluated
at the expected value of X.
So this is what Jensen's
inequality says,
but for a more
general distribution
for the random variable X. Let
us now step back and define
more precisely what it means
for a function to be convex.
The most general definition
is the following.
If I take any two
points, x and y,
and I take some number
p between 0 and 1.
So in that case, the
number px plus 1 minus py
is a weighted
average of x and y--
so it's somewhere in the middle.
And if I look at the
value of my function
at that particular
point-- so this value here
corresponds to
this-- this is less
than or equal to the weighted
average of the values of g
of x and g of y.
So this is g of x.
This is g of y.
This value here is the weighted
average of the two values.
So this quantity here is p times
g of x, which is this value,
plus 1 minus p, g of y.
Convexity means that this
value is below that value.
Or in other words, whenever I
take two points on this curve
and join them by a
segment, then the function
lies underneath that segment.
This is one possible definition.
Now, in terms of
a picture, we see
that a convex function
tends to curve upwards.
This means that the derivative
or the slope of the function
keeps increasing.
An increasing slope means
that the second derivative
of that function
is non-negative.
And that could be an alternative
definition of convexity.
It turns out that if you
have a function that's
twice differentiable, these
two definitions are equivalent.
On the other hand,
the first definition
is a little more
general, because it also
applies to functions
that are not smooth.
So for example, the
function absolute value of x
is a convex one.
But it's not
differentiable at zero.
Finally, there's another
way of defining convexity,
and it is the
following property,
again for differentiable
functions.
What it says is the following.
If I fix a certain point,
c-- to use the same diagram
let's say that this
is c-- this value here
is going to be g of c.
I look at the derivative
of that function and take
this quantity, which is the
derivative times how far I
am going.
This quantity here is a
first-order Taylor series
approximation of my function.
So it corresponds
to this black line.
What this condition says
is that the function
lies on top of that tangent
line to my function.
It is not too difficult to
show that this condition,
non-negative second derivatives,
implies this condition.
What you do is that you write
down the second order Taylor
approximation of
your function g.
And then because the
second order term
is going to be non-negative
because of that condition,
you're going to get an
inequality in this form.
But in any case, this
inequality is pretty intuitive.
And we could take this
one just as our definition
of convexity-- that is,
a function is convex
if it has the property
that whenever I draw
a tangent to my curve,
the function lies
on top of this linear function.
So now let's move
back to probability.
Suppose that g is convex.
This is true for every x.
So in particular, if I
have my random variable,
capital X, no matter what
my random variable is,
we're going to get this kind
of inequality, no matter what.
And here what I they
left blank is c.
Now, c is a number.
This is true for any number.
So in particular, it's
true if I use as my number
the expected value of X.
So we have this inequality
that's true now in terms
of random variables.
No matter what capital X happens
to be, this will be valid.
And now let us take
expectations of both sides.
What we obtain is that the
expected value of g of X
is larger than-- now,
this is a number,
so the expected
value of that number
is the number itself plus the
expected value of this term.
This quantity is a number.
The expected value of X
minus the expected value of X
is equal to 0.
And we have established
this particular fact,
which is true for
any convex function.
So this is Jensen's inequality.
Let's apply it to some examples.
Let's consider the
function g, which
is the quadratic function.
Clearly, this is
a convex function.
It has this kind of shape.
And the second derivative of
this function is positive.
That's another way
of verifying it.
Jensen's inequality
is going to tell us
something about the
expected value of X squared.
Now, for this
expectation, we already
know that this is equal to the
variance of X plus the square
of the expected value.
And since the variance
is always non-negative,
we obtain this inequality.
This is consistent with
Jensen's inequality.
Jensen's inequality tells
us that E of g of X,
with g the quadratic
function, is
larger than or equal
to the square-- that
is, g of the expected value.
So for the case of
the square function,
Jensen's inequality did
not tell us anything
that we didn't know.
But it's nice to confirm
that it is consistent.
But we could use
Jensen's inequality
in another setting where the
answer might not be as obvious.
For example, take the
function X to the fourth.
This is also a convex function.
And Jensen's inequality
is going to tell us
that the fourth power of the
expected value is less than
or equal to the expected
value of X to the fourth.
Another case of
a convex function
is the negative logarithm.
Remember that the
logarithmic function
has a shape of this kind,
which curves the opposite way.
So it's called a
concave function.
But if you take the
negative of this function,
then you're going to get
something that is convex.
So by applying
Jensen's inequality
to this setting,
what we obtain is
that g, which is minus log
of the expected value of X,
is less than or equal to the
expected value of minus log X.
And then we can remove the
minus signs from both sides.
And that is going to
reverse the inequality.
And we will obtain that the
logarithm of the expected value
of X is larger than or equal
to the expected value of log X.
So in this case for the
logarithmic function,
the inequality goes in
the opposite direction.
The reason is that the
logarithmic function
is a concave function,
not a convex one.
And by arguing similar
to this example,
a concave function is the
negative of a convex function.
And for concave functions,
Jensen's inequality still
holds, but the inequality
goes the opposite way.
Jensen's inequality turns
out to be quite useful.
In many cases, we
want to say something
about the expected
value of g of X,
and Jensen's inequality
allows us to do that.